non vedo l'ora di vedere la faccia che
farà l'italia dove trattava gira
ferrando tutto il mondo la situazione
qui dietro solo vittoria
avete presente sul tavolo il nuovo
challenge se lo costruisci il telo copro
allora vi spiego prossimamente come
funziona la vedrete dei feti giganti di
lego ma dentro tutti le cosiddette
esistono leggo piccoli praticamente una
volta a stessa il vitale dovremo
costruire qualcosa con i lego e non
dovremmo dire all'altra persona che
cos'è una persona deve indovinare che
cos'è quella forma indovina stato
persona dove comprarli
non so se si è capito mastico biasi che
soffrirà mentre pare molto gradevole e
divertente lasciato un bel mi piace se
questo video raggiunge i 15 mila mi
piace farlo anche da seconda parte che
avremo quattro turni pronto per iniziare
abbiamo iniziato
catapano ricercato da 200gr bianche
bisogna dire dove cominciamo a
ricostruirlo è così cosa costruisco di
cercare di parlare il più somigliante
possibile correre così se io indovino
la coop rosa il nodo vino lo prende
liete rimarrete da storico invitare che
proverà allora una cosa che vorrei che
ha ritenuto minasse che quindi prova a
costruirlo e il mio nintendo lui
dobbiamo vedere se con tutto quanto per
costruirlo quindi vorrei cominciare a
mettere sul tavolo tutti quanti i lego a
disposizione rosso blu perfetti proprio
tutto questo dove trovarono perso per
fare lo schermo spicca diciamo che non è
proprio lo schermo ideale per la per la
nintendo questo piano qualcosa prenderà
forma adesso faccio un problema come
faccio a collegare questo che amo questo
qui che secondo me è perfetto come
schermo
rimediamo possiamo mettere questa parte
blu qui blu rosa come blu e questa
blocco e poi fai come possiamo fare i
controller
potrebbero essere queste i bottoni mai
non entra ecco un carino forse meglio se
mette un altro di questo trucco equa
ok tipo controller così no
a gelare tipo così mi piace che cosa ne
pensate
e un'intesa switch fantastica da qui si
possono mettere i giochi questo fa da
schermo allora adesso che mi umanità e
vediamo cosa ne pensa lei è qui
che cosa hai creato cos'è questa cosa
prima finendo nono nella finestra una
porta si apre anche perderebbero
contrario così che dovresti vederlo
perché in genere la portabilità di apre
così mi devi dare qualche indizio perché
a me sembra una porta con fermaporta
sotto forma porto e quello che verrà è
una camera di sicurezza questa ok quindi
mi stai comprando dal fare l'attrice ma
che cosa vuoi
questa la devi tenere chiusa posso dire
che quello uno schermo così si può dire
che siamo quindi una sorta di tivù tivù
che questi cosa c'entrano non lo so
secondo te che cosa sono quelli e quelli
sul lato anche ci sono sul lato dei
perché dopo il vino francese è un
videogioco si ho capito ho capito solo
dai colori
altrimenti nostre è arrivata e una
nintendo si laurea presso gli stand sui
dati un voto questa creazione di vitale
[Risate]
[Musica]
[Applauso]
abbiamo quindi possiamo comparare la
creazione di vitale con la mera qui
assomiglia veramente viene messo bucchi
i colori sono mai pensavo fossero invece
è pure io penso fossero arancione il
colore me lo aspettavo completamente
diverso votate se la costruzione di
brutale si somiglia cosa si assomiglia
da 1 a 10
certo è ora i ragazzi tocca a me allora
una cosa che vorrei visto che ora c'è
anche l'altro sfizio e anche voglio da
quando è uscita è il nuovo gioco di
pokémon pokémon scudo e spada in realtà
non sapevo se preferivo spada o scudo ma
ho visto che in scudo c'è l'evoluzione
di buoni ta unicorno tutto il colorato
bellissimo comunque non ha idea di come
parla con i lego farlo stavo provando a
fare tipo uno dei pokémon scor bambini
sembra che si chiama in gomma e i vigili
stimo non solo così bravo usa rileggo
quindi ho pensato una cosa potrà
ricostruire con i lego
la confezione del gioco dei pokémon poi
con la stampante stampo l'immagine
piccolino l'attacco sopra così
sicuramente vitale non si può sbagliare
allora proviamo innanzitutto costruire
una confezione ho visto che la
confezione
quindi cerchiamo qualcosa
questo potrebbe funzionare però è troppo
piegato quindi devo trovare qualcosa di
più piatto questo forse questo però devo
fare un pochino più grande perché questo
è troppo rettangolare farle un po più
quadrato e posso usare questi due questo
pezzetto qua dietro ovviamente così non
si capisce un cavolo sembra solo una
mattonella bianche a un quadro quindi
ora devo andare a stampare l'immagine di
pochi amo scudo un dio che è qua lo
stato approvato guardate il sito
piccolino e da salvo stampato anche
primo vestito troppo piccolo non si vede
niente
qua dovrebbe esser che per ritagliarlo
vediamo che carino ora prova in con la
rupa o no ma è troppo grande
devo tagliata un pochettino perché
troppo grande è tornato berlino a cui
l'affare arrivate da mad regia cru
dell'azienda pokemon scudo fatto con i
legamenti la verità le riesce a capirlo
ma non può non capirlo si legge da qua
vita le reti
e ricostruzione pronta se come vediamo
in quanto tempo indovini numero e mi
sembra abbastanza facile e che cos'è
davvero più vitale non ci vede ha
bisogno degli occhiali sono mai collata
di rotta per salutare un pokémon
no mai
non la trovo no non c'è
eccolo trovato proprio lo scudo è viva
non vedo l'ora di vedere come andiamo ad
aprire penso che si sia rotto qualcosa
e c'è una schedina ecco la schedina mi
chiamo queste ripresa cos'è il bravo nel
gioco di carte col tocco di carta e per
questo devo giocare a carte e tutta la
scheda sd rotto tecnologici ma mi ha un
figlio max disponibile fino al 15
gennaio quindi è praticamente ho letto
che questo ho avuto cose in pokémon
pokémon diventano giga max cioè
diventano giganteschi battaglia solo in
alcuni momenti quindi sono proprio
curiosa di vederlo non vedo l'ora di
giocarci anch'io mi piace se volete
vedere del gameplay come l'anno scorso
sul canale digitale in cui giochiamo
assieme a pokémon
fatecelo sapere nei commenti se non
siete ancora si cercano di vita la dat
estivi al canale di evitare che ci siano
il canale di ritardo e salmeri dovete
sapere una cosa
prima quando siamo usciti trovato pi
greco particolari perché in realtà noi
dovremo utilizzare questi leve qui per
costruire che sono degli standard ce ne
sono tanti se idea e poi costruire tante
cose però io visto che si indovina
quello che costruisco melo con tra
cordate che cosa ho trovato non vedo
l'ora di vedere la faccia che farà edita
da dove tratta banchina ferrara è enorme
più da dell'istruzione wow
ci sono un sacco di pezzi non mi
aspettavo di trovare di tristi casi
all'interno un sacco di cerchi e
cerchioli aiuto come faccio a pavia con
le istruzioni o sa che devo seguirle
perché con tutti questi pezzi altrimenti
è impossibile correre la macchina va beh
ci sono addirittura gli adesivi per fare
tutti i dettagli ferrari wow stupendo
cominciamo subito il meccanico il
meccanico e pirola come il meccanico
il pilota ora no non partiamo dal pilota
partiamo subito dal dalla struttura
della macchina che sarebbe questa crisi
il pilota è pronto nel frattempo si è
fatto buio ma ci sono riuscito guardate
guardate wow è stupenda e fatto
benissimo tra l'altro non potrà fare
sinistralità ora comprare adesso la
chiamano aspetta però prima devo
togliere tutte queste cose qui perché
altrimenti se ne accorge e c'è anche il
pilota avevo dimenticato il comfort a
volte queste cose ci ho impiegato un
sacco di tempo spero non si
insospettisca anita a vita
ripiegate diventato un poco io ho capito
però difficile arriva ora guarda però
che cos'ha detto
indovinate cosa metti capisse che cos'è
bellissima d'altronde nissimo il volante
volante si volante google ha già fatto
benissimo sono stato attento ha scelto
tutti i pezzettini giusti avevamo tutti
questi pezzi e rossi si alcuni dovuti
dipingere bros
e qualcosa nei dipinti che con la
fantastica
c'è qualcosa che non quadra gioia o
pratavecchia basta troppo ciao ragazzi
ho preso una cosa per evitare allora
innanzitutto era impossibile che
prendessi quella macchina perché non
riuscirei mai a permettermela poi c'era
qualcosa di strano perché io sono sicura
che non abbiamo
non avevamo tutti quei pezzi rossi di
leggo
quindi non è possibile che lui si è
riuscito a costruirla
o come il sospetto che mi abbia
imbrogliato in qualche modo che sia
uscito a comprarla modelli già montata
non lo so comunque avrà quello che per
quello che si merita perché guardate che
cosa ho preso testa identica macchinetta
che ha costruito una ferrari rossa e
moderno
non so se non vi potrà tv niente perché
lui ha detto che dovevo comprare in
quella macchina è in effetti questa è la
macchina quindi ora vediamo come il real
cis
ho parcheggiato la sua nuova macchina
fuori
sì certo aspetta devi andare a sederti
un momento gr ti portachiavi e
parate del buio attorno sul filo devo
far vedere le chiavi
[Musica]
allora sì una patente speciale per
visitare questa macchina o basta la mia
prima che ti do le chiavi migliori dire
la verità la verità nient'altro che la
verità solo la verità dove hai comprato
questa macchinetta fatta coi lego anche
berlino vuole sapere in partita
spareggio sulla sedia dove l'hai
comprata anche già montata o non montato
io non so su de paula però non erano i
nostri leggo mi hai comprati a porta è
vero nei nostri perché li ho comprati io
per noi quindi erano i nostri leggo la
sapevo che il imbrogliate qualche volta
sì questa è la tua macchina quindi
questa è la macchina che ti meriti
vissuta comprarli non c'è un negozio di
giocattoli un ottimo modellino ma è una
vera ferrari e corrisponde alle regole
del gioco ribbon quale va bene ci devo
stare non riesco la prima dopo questa l
f 40
e questa l fc qua da chiesta io per me
sono tutte uguali
ma sono quasi nel modello primo volo f50
che di ben preso pure il modello più
nuovo
ok allora eccole qua
si vede giusto io no è vero non avete
già controllando vediamo come reagisce
[Musica]
no ma io non ci voglio a questa è la
macchina di lusso non si mangia bene
oggi vitale l'ha portato a lavare a fare
la toelettatura infatti non sono state
date ma sembra un po più chiaro guardate
come il bianco perchè punitivi e anche
morbidissimo il profumo di dibattito
ok ragazzi tocca a me l'ultimo turno
allora sto gioco è stato di creare
praticamente quadravano al negozio ho
visto un gioco per suite siccome ora
anche la suite vitale che è una specie
di cerchio un ring si chiama schei gioco
scrivano benfit una specie di cerchio e
devi giocare ma allo stesso tempo ti
potevi schiacciare questo cerchio devi
abbassarti devi spostarti quindi
praticamente mentre giochi spetti stai
allenando stai facendo ginnastica stai
facendo il nuovo sacco di cose e ho
pensato che delinea le attivissimo per
tenersi in forma e ma divertirsi anche
quindi voglio provare a ricreare quel
gioco vitale saggiati che gioco si
tratta perché io ho fatto vedere un
picchio tempo fa quintili non so se
riuscirà però a indovinarlo perché io
proverò proprio a creare un link quindi
un anello come nel gioco
chiediamo se ci riesco con questi
pezzettini che i ragazzi l'ho fatto ma
ho paura che non lo capirà mai questo
qua e il ring che ho fatto quindi quel
con la specie di coso che senza per
questo gioco è vero il mini joystiq che
in realtà si deve attaccare che è di
joystiq sarebbe quello della suite
quindi è il rossoblu proverò questo
pezzo era stato in blu non capirò mai
che cos'è tale prati allora devi
concentrarti perché questo è l'ultimo
tiro di concentrare cos'è questa cosa un
fondo di pietra per fare la pizza quale
l'avrebbe mi sembra una cosa rotonda un
anello da perché dovrebbe essere così
grande e rosso aspetta c'è un altro
indizio che questa è un'altra cosa che
non posso dirti che cos'è che si deve
attaccare a questo anelli anni
che ci si può giocare con questo sì ci
si può giocare ai videogame mantenendo
si sia mai fatto credo di averlo
sistemato allora il secondo me il ring
fitta ventures come fatto ricordarti
perché praticamente mi avevi detto ti
piaceva tantissimo stava guardando
sempre i video su youtube di mai stati
nel destino
[Musica]
secondo il mio design cerchia andiamo ad
aprirlo di cosa se volete fare un
gameplay potevo sapere nei commenti e
lasciate un mi piace questo video non
c'è ma non mi hanno messo un ragazzo che
nessuno capisca che se il gioco
questo palma motoring di cui ti parlavo
italiano cerchio vediamo in effetti è
abbastanza solo da stringere perché fa
ha detto così e fare trovare allargato
secondo me se lo diamo marlino ci
impiega 30 di uguale invece è il gioco
sempre per svizzere
mi raccomando se le videocamere migrar
di testa fa e la band ad allegare invece
da mettere nel
nella gamba perché rileva immobiliare
mettete la gamba si sta già eccolo qua
non c'è niente remo aveva semplicemente
corso mini schedina
non vedo l'ora di provarlo se volete
provarlo stiamo a noi lasciato un bel mi
piace questo video volete vedere la
seconda parte la7 un bel mi piace e alla
fine siamo qua quattro casalinghe spiuk
il caro puoi vedere i vostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite